З першого візиту Меркель до Трампа цей момент запам'ятався найбільше.
Президент США демонстративно проігнорував канцлерку ФРН,
коли вона запитала його про ще одне рукостискання для камер.
Такі символічні кадри політичного непорозуміння
актуальні й нині, через рік після першої зустрічі двох лідерів.
Приводів для непорозумінь навіть стало більше.
Меркель усе ще має статус найвпливовішої жінки світу,
яка вправно справляється з владними чоловіками-політиками.
А Трамп тут радше виняток.
Президент США прагне одноосібно визначати час та напрямок.
Непередбачуваність Трампа не вкладається в рамки політичної культури Меркель,
яка бачить себе поборницею західних цінностей.
Минулого року стало вкрай очевидним, що Дональд Трамп  частково готовий
поставити під питання наш міжнародний порядок і відповідно правові рамки,
на яких зрештою базуються, зокрема, й відносини із США.
Трамп дуже швидко дав зрозуміти партнерам по НАТО,
йому йдеться не про цінності, а про гроші.
23 з 28 країн-членів НАТО все ще не витрачають на свою оборону
стільки, скільки вони мусять витрачати.
Після першої зустрічі Меркель змушена була тверезо визнати,
наскільки швидко Трамп готовий поставити під питання цінності,
які обєднують країни в "західний альянс".
Часи, коли ми могли цілковито покластися на інших, вже позаду.
З часу президентства Трампа Німеччині зі своєю позицією
вкрай складно вийти на  владну орбіту нового керівництва США.
Нерозв'язані нагальні питання лише накопичуються.
Є три суперечливі теми на трансатлантичному порядку денному.
Перша - це торгівля між США та Європою.
Друга - угода з Іраном.
І третя тема - це внески Європи і зокрема Німеччини до НАТО.
Тобто витрати ФРН на оборону та військові місії.
За дві з половиною години,
передбачені для нової зустрічі Меркель та Трампа в Білому домі,
навряд чи вдасться щось вирішити.
Нечасто очікування від візиту на найвищому рівні бувають таким низькими.